I am someone who wakes up in a different
body every day always someone my age I
never to first in the last never the
same person twice and I have absolutely
no control over any of it the day that
Amy shadowed us or I was Amy the day
that you went to the beach with Justin I
was Justin it's not possible it is hey
it's me every day of your life you've
just woken up and just try to live that
day before that person that sounds
really well it isn't because I know what
makes each person different and what
makes everyone the same why are you
doing this day we met I felt something
I've never felt before I don't want to
let that go
I am so proud thank you
I'm in love with someone who wakes up in
a different body every day always the
same age never the same person twice
there's such a bright beautiful kind
funny person Michael tomorrow wake up as
the kid who's not flying back here oh my
god this kid is not exercise
[Music]
I have to go wait who even was that
[Music]
I'm forcing Alexander out of his own
life it's wrong what are you saying
think about what happens if you and I
stay together we can make it work I want
to believe that
[Music]
what will happen to your life if I'm the
person in the world that you're closest
to you know I thought you'd left left I
never leave doing everyday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]